one of the changes you want to do and
that you're passionate about is making
it easier to vote yes now what do you
specifically mean making it easier to
vote
well first thought we have voter
turnouts which are some of the lowest in
the industrialized world I think in this
last election 54 55 % of the people
voted 45 percent did not what does it
mean in many countries around the world
you have automatic voter registration
you are 18 years of age guess what you
are registered to vote end of discussion
that does away with the whole effort to
add voter suppression it simply makes
everybody eligible to vote I want to see
that I want to see same-day registration
all over this country so that if you
have not registered to vote as of now
you can on Election Day
register to vote I want online voter
registration I want to make it easier
for people to vote by mail or a vote
earlier now what is going on and it
should be of concern to every American
is the Republicans are working very very
hard they work on overtime to literally
suppress the vote to make it harder for
people to participate and that really to
me is revolting because I'll tell you
why look we can disagree on issues but
to go out of your way to make it harder
for poor people or people of color to
register and vote is anti-american
to the nth degree when I say when I say
to those Republican governors who are
trying to suppress the vote if you don't
have the guts to participate in a free
fair and open election get out of
politics and get another job
the technology obviously exists for
people to vote online and we're
increasingly becoming an online society
is that something that worries you do
you think that's too vulnerable I think
it probably is but we can do what many
other countries do and that is automatic
voter registration when you're 18 we
know people who are gonna be 18 you're
automatically registered to vote no
problem okay it's clear now despite what
president-elect Trump says that Hillary
Clinton won the popular vote by a wide
margin a million votes two million votes
and Donald Trump won the electoral
college should we still have the
electoral college in your opinion look
on the surface when you have one
candidate who wins an election by two
million votes and is not being
inaugurated on the surface that sounds
pretty crazy to me number two what
happens now is that in our elections
there are about 15-20 battleground
states 30 states like California or
Vermont they vote Democratic you know
Wyoming and South Dakota will vote
Republican nobody pays attention to
those states so to answer your question
I think we do have to rethink the
Electoral College from my perspective
the person who gets the most votes
should win the election
you